what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future okay so what the
Logan movie coming out in the next few
months or so I was trying to figure out
what kind of Wolverine content that I
was gonna do you know because I want to
touch on to some Wolverine stuff just
because of the fact that there's a lot
of great Wolverine stories out there but
I was like if I'm gonna jump into it I
can't just jump into the middle of a
Wolverine story I can't just do like
Wolverine kills Sabretooth I mean I'm
sure you guys would love to see that
well you can't just like jump in vet you
kind of have to work your way up to it
and so the idea was alright if we're
gonna do that then where do we start
well I mean that was like I could start
with Wolverines origin I guess but
that's been done to death everyone has
done Wolverines origin and you better
believe when the movie starts coming out
they're gonna do his origin again so I
was like I may do that at some point
long line but the one story that like
no-one's ever done is the story of how
Wolverine got his adamantium skeleton no
one ever really talked about that no
this story came to us actually between
March of September of 1991 and it was
written by a guy named Barry
windsor-smith one thing to keep in mind
with the story though is that virtually
nothing was known about Wolverine up to
this point and the reason why was
because Wolverine as he had been created
by Chris Claremont and Len Wein was
really just designed to be this
extremely intrinsic mysterious character
he wasn't designed to have a great big
huge grandiose backstory but the fact
that he was so mysterious is what made
him so popular because everybody wanted
to know were these little fragments of
memories were coming from what in the
world is Weapon X was Canada's
department cake how does all I kind of
stuff come together to form the
backstory of Wolverine now for those of
you guys who are familiar with his
history bear with me for a second while
I kind of whatever that's for a lot of
you guys who aren't so in Marvel Comics
are bit a lot of retroactively
continuities men either have been
writers that have come in and they
basically changed the past by
introducing new things and so on and so
forth the first major of these involving
the Wolverine came in 1992 with Chris
Claremont and Jim Lee and what they did
is they introduced a group called Team X
and what they said was that Wolverine
was part of this black ops group called
Team X alongside Sabretooth Silver Fox
and maverick I think and they basically
carried out these clandestine
organizations for canada's department
cave which was like their version of the
CIA which was funded by the united
states CIA the reason why was because if
all of this went south they were caught
in a mission or something like that
the mission was botched all the blame
would fall on Canada and the United
States could just walk away without
having their hands caught in the cookie
jar what then happened is in 2001 this
writer Grant Morrison came along and
Grant Morrison said no no there's a lot
more to it than that there's this weird
organism named john sublime they came to
the realization that mutants are immune
to john supply was a mind-control and so
sublime wanted to get rid of all the
mutants and so what it did is it said we
need to basically create super soldiers
that can wipe out mutants Captain
America was the first one but it was a
program called weapons Plus that was
created using information gathered by
mr. sinister during his weird
experiments during world war ii you but
after Captain America's successful
transition to the super soldier but
because of the fact that dr. Abraham
Erskine had died John sublime had to
basically start from scratch and so
there was weapons 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
landing ultimately with Weapon X Weapon
10 which is where we got Wolverine and
then of course we got Deadpool with
Weapon 11 now following this Daniel way
came along in something like 2008 2009
2010 something like that I can't
remember but he wrote a series of
stories called Wolverine Origins
and what he came back and did is he
basically said all that John sublime
stuff is nonsense there was just this
guy named Ronan who was part of the
Weapon X project
he basically spearheaded the whole thing
and he turned Logan into Wolverine
there's been a lot of retcons a lot of
changes and a lot of it's really really
confusing and so for the sake of this
story what we're gonna do is we're gonna
use a clean slate and we're just gonna
more or less go with the idea that Barry
windsor-smith was going with that we
didn't know anything about Wolverine
before this and so essentially the
entire comic in the beginning
initially focuses on this kind of back
and forth it's like this montage you
know where Wolverines giving us this
monologue but it's kind of chilly back
and forth of course work Logan himself
is being trapped by some really shady
cloak-and-dagger kind of guys but we
also have a guy named Abraham Cornelius
who's looking over various phone numbers
who's making various phone calls we have
the guy you know professor Treuer who's
bringing on Carol Hines
it's really kind of setting the stage
for what will become this Weapon X
project now Wolverine was not their
first attempt to bond adamantium to the
skeleton of a human being instead they
had done it in several different places
they'd done it on monkeys they've done
it on actual regular people but all of
them were failures for whatever reason
they were just grotesque failures but
the most common Ares of Hawaii didn't
work is because their bodies just
couldn't handle the adamantium process
their bodies would basically just shut
down because it was too much for the
other body
could recover from the extensive
injuries that came about with metal
being drafted to the human skeleton and
so because of that basically all of them
died and so again it was really just
continuing the process of just running
around and snatching people so again
because of the fact that windsor-smith
was going with the idea that nothing was
known about Logan and the idea that the
professor true it that dr. Cornelius
that Harrell Hines
the fact they didn't know that a Logan
had a healing factor meant that when
they grabbed him it was just sheer luck
that had happened at workout but of
course what he's taken under you know
he's immediately stripped of all of his
clothes he's shaved and his entirety and
he's just that we hooked up to a whole
bunch of tubes and everything so again a
lot of this is kind of going back and
forth but there are a little spotty
references here and there that
windsor-smith makes to the idea that
Wolverine had a healing factor and
nobody knew the first and most notable
of these is that when he's shot with a
tranquilizer he recovers pretty fast now
ultimately they just kind of take him
out the old-fashioned way and just you
know knock him out with brute force but
ways take it to the Weapon X facility
again it's just this great big huge
experimentation and all it is for a lot
of this is really just kind of bonding
him with adamantium sending the
adamantium in and they're doing it in
stages and the reason for this is
because adamantium is quite literally
just a liquid metal if they were to
throw it all into his body at one time
there's no telling what would happen it
could simply be that there was just too
much for it autographed at one time and
so he's just got adamantium floating in
his veins and his body just kind of gets
ripped apart at the seams but the idea
here is that once it's set it'll Harden
and become the strongest metal on the
face of the planet now to talk about
this for a second because I imagine a
lot of people have questions about like
adamantium one of the most common
questions that I see is like which one's
stronger adamantium or vibranium now we
talked about this before but it can
never hurt to rehash an interesting
question like this so in the realm of
Marvel comics you have all different
kinds of metals but the three most
popular or I guess the three most
durable are Rou metal atom antium and
then vibranium vibranium is literally
just some material that came from space
somewhere nobody really knows where it
came from
it landed on earth it was discovered by
primitive wakandans who viewed it as
their honor I guess their job according
to the Panther God bast to basically
guard the adamantium the first or I
guess the greatest of these wakandans
was bestowed with the powers of the path
of God mass becoming the first Black
Panther another part of vibranium landed
in Antarctica and it gave it a whole
different set of properties as so what
Condon vibranium basically has the
ability
to manipulate energy absorb energy
absorb sound different things like that
and then use those sound waves that have
been absorbed to essentially make it
more durable Antarctic vibranium
literally just breaks down objects and
substances on the molecular level so
it's like the ultimate knife is really
kind of the best way to think about it
uber metal is Anna chanted metal from
one of the realms of Asgard but the
metal can be enchanted more so than it
normally is to basically absorb magical
energy that's the kind of metal that you
find in Thor's hammer that's why I like
dr. Strange's magic doesn't work on Thor
because if you were to try to use it for
wood just absorb the magic with his
hammer
it would make the hammer stronger and
then dr. trades probably get his head
knocked off finally when it comes to
adamantium there's several different
types there's true adamantium there is
regular adamantium there's false
adamantium which is what you find with
carbonadium which is basically like
Russia's cheap version of adamantium but
true adamantium was discovered by
accident in Marvel College what had
happened was what Captain America had
been presented with a shield by the
wakandans after helping to fight off the
Nazi Party I guess Troxy soldiers during
World War two not only did he witness
how aerodynamic their shields were
because they were around but he was also
presented with a small piece of
vibranium by the wakandan King and so
what Captain America did is he came back
to the United States he commissioned the
US government to create a new shield
which was round and then make that
shield out of vibranium the issue was
that the professor and I want to say his
name is Professor Smith the metallurgist
who was putting the shield together I
had basically fallen asleep at the wheel
and in the process some chemicals got
mixed in which I think it was actually
iron and a couple other things and it
resulted in this weird hybrid metal
compound which is why Captain America's
shield is the only thing stronger than
adamantium but in the process of trying
to duplicate the material that makes up
Captain America's shield this guy
accidentally discovered adamantium
that's what's called true adamantium and
I believe that the bones are I guess the
skeleton of Wolverine may be the cause
of Sabretooth there's maybe like one or
two maybe three people that actually
have true adamantium everything else is
just a cheap knockoff
it's everybody else's attempt to try to
duplicate adamantium but that's more or
less kind of how that works and the
realm of Marvel Comics but what
Wolverine is getting right here is real
tried and true legitimate adamantium but
again you know once adamantium hardens
it's impossible to destroy it you can't
take it apart you can't do anything
it is impossible to destroy I think that
the only instance worse really been like
dented or damaged in any real way was
when Thor started beating on adamantium
with his hammer and it dented a little
bit but it didn't like tear a hole and
or anything but the fact remains here
that because of the fact that Wolverine
is literally recovering from the
adamantium body process far faster than
he should be this begins to raise
questions among Carroll Hines and the
professor and dr. Abraham Cornelius now
the professor basically vacates and is
kind of Westar mysterious as to why but
we basically find out that he's talking
to a third party we don't know who that
person is but he's talking to them and
what he reveals is that the professor
himself did not know that Logan was a
mutant he did not know that Logan had an
instantaneous healing factor and so
they're all learning about this for the
first time but this is also a blessing
in disguise because it makes Logan the
perfect host for adamantium because as
the adamantium goes into his body as it
tries to burn away at the bones because
it's so incredibly hot the bones will
just begin to heal themselves at a rapid
pace as it starts to melt through the
skin because it's so hot the skin will
heal at a rapid pace and so once the
cooling process happens and the
adamantium bonds to the bones it'll be
perfect it'll be a perfect example of a
person who successfully had adamantium
bonded to their skeleton the problem
with this is that Wolverine where this
healing factor is also beginning to
emerge is also beginning to somewhat
come - now initially what he begins to
sort of wake up he doesn't actually
attack everybody instead what happens is
his professor true it is actually met
from some young intern who's basically
in the lab keeping an eye on Wolverine
while Cornelius and Heinz are not there
and he basically says that Wolverine is
waking up and he's looking at his hands
now this is the first time that we
actually get any indication of
Wolverines claws popping and that's why
people said for the longest time that
Wolverine didn't have claws until he
received adamantium bonding we learned
more recently in the Wolverine origin
story that Wolverine always had claws
and they were made of bone that's why it
was such a huge revelation in fatal
attractions when Wolverine had the
adamantium torn from his body and then
he popped his claws that he had bone
claws and also was why we ended up
getting feral Wolverine when he was just
a crazy guy living in the woods and just
attacking everything that he saw I was
actually kind of a really cool series of
stories I think there were a lot of
comics based on that I think was like
savage Wolverine but the fact remains
here that when these claws pop again you
know they're Adam Ant
in response to this Professor true it
actually tells that intern kid go in
there see what's going on you know
investigate make sure you shed the
security door behind you in case
anything happens now following this of
course we have like Abraham Cornelius
and he grabs a couple of guards with him
to basically go into the lab and see
what's going on
due to the alarms and when they get in
there wolverine had essentially killed
this guy and so as this volume is first
you know a little section starts to come
to a close it's really just the idea
that wolf reign has effectively come to
and so what'll happen next is you know
the final stages of adamantium bonding
followed by what is essentially the most
torturous aspect of this story where
wolverine is forced to receive false
memories and then train to become a
killing machine but with that being said
if you guys are new here to comics
explained and you guys enjoy videos like
this then make sure you hit the
subscribe button to become part of the
robb core and leave a like if you guys
thought this was kind of cool leave a
comment down below let me know what you
guys think and I will catch you all
better peace
[Music]